Sascha's a new movie is called the
brothers Grimsby Sasha is a soccer
hooligan I did some research you know so
these guys particularly in the 80s you
know football matches would be
incredibly violent and they used to be
very well-planned these fights between
different local crews so I went up to
the north of England I met up with the
most famous and violent soccer crew
you're out of your [ __ ] mind anyway
so I said I knew it's gonna be dangerous
so I hired a bodyguard right and the
bodyguard said to me guys listen just so
you know I'm gonna be blending in John I
guess if anyone knows you've got a
bodyguard you're in trouble right
Sunny's got beer in his head like
blending in yeah Hey look at him again
the piers finished and then he's getting
the bar again and I look at him and it
within a half an hour he's unconscious
asleep oh my god I wish he's unconscious
sir I mean with you find his [ __ ] I
don't he was a local guy he's the guy
the worst bodyguard ever well-vetted
sure I'm there with these hooligans i
septum okay listen okay I go listen if
you got any funny stories about when you
were a hooligan he goes because there
was one time I was in Manchester we we
kidnapped this man was brought him back
to his house and we put barbed wire on
places on his body that we shouldn't
live and then we blew up his garage and
I said have you got any even funnier
story story and then I went to the
bathroom and then there's this really
small member of this the special crew
comes in and he's got stab marks all
over his face you know their scars all
over his face and I go can help you
because there's at me here to protect
you
I go what do you mean he goes somebody
got stabbed in this toilet last week I
go I said who was that because me I
thought you're probably not the guy to
protect me you know